hallo leute sind wieder einmal waren und
willkommen zu einer neuen folge wie
schmeckt durch mein outfit und dem video
titel hat die wahrscheinlichen raten was
wir heute machen
carryquote baby kekse aus the walking
dead und jetzt fragten wahrscheinlich
ganz schön viele von euch auch weil ich
das wieder mal ganz auf gewünscht habt
werdet aber nicht spoilern warum will
die kekse macht wo sie ist um überhaupt
das könnt ihr dann selber nachschauen
zweite woche der ganz gesehen hat tut es
mir ziemlich gute serie und für die
unter euch die folge auf gesehen haben
ich weiß immer genau so bestand und ich
wie diese knickel am ende schmecken
bärbel mit gut in bewegung kann man mir
für den zutaten und da habe ich mich mal
wieder selbst übertroffen
ich habe mich heute noch mal auf youtube
angeschaut am anfang gibt so ein short
in der abstellkammer über die
lebensmittel und carol greift nach und
nach zum taten als erstes kreis genutzt
um einmachglas und weißem pulver drin
und ich dafür dass das mehl und
puderzucker und dann habe ich ganz klein
gut gelesen und ich habe erst mal bei
google eingegeben und es ist ein puzzle
das heißen im glas ist viel drin und ich
dachte dass es niemals finden werde aber
unser veganer laden und dann kam die
nächste schwierigkeit begreift nach
einer dose auf der watch as platz steht
was pakistan hatte ich in meinem leben
noch nie gesehen
dann war ich im supermarkt noch keine
wasser kastanien gefunden als ob ich
machen gekauft und dafür okay dass
bildung im pass doch dann bin ich an
einem supermarkt vorbei gelaufen und was
hatten sie dagegen
rochester so weit so gut war die nächste
zu datum so einfach zu finden
rote beete bei der nächsten tag musste
ich ein bisschen raten und mich im
internet schlau machen und ich glaube es
ist kakaopulver und zwar in finns
kakaopulver wenn wir auch in die hand
und das ist so eine braune brühe die
gemacht und nicht weißt es von diesem
kakaopulver das auch so grimmig werden
kann und bei richtigen wacker kauf habe
ich das noch nie gesehen dass der so
komisch wird kann auch natürlich seien
hier sogar noch ein bisschen zucker drin
also verkauft und wieder schaut sie es
nicht mehr eine abstellkammer sondern
draußen und sammelt haselnüsse zwei
gefahrene für mit schale kaufen haben
aber nicht gefunden und wir sind ja
schließlich in einer kombi apokalypse
unter frauen mit den zutaten und jetzt
geht man zu machen
sorry dass ich die ganze zeit aus licht
ändert ich bin direkt vorm fenster und
heute so ein tag wo die sonne
wieder rauskommt und nicht und ja und
nein deswegen sind wir hier auf youtube
sehr gute ausbildung die man sich
vorstellt youtube da musst halt so man
sieht zwar nicht wie kliniken zubereitet
aber wenn sie aus dem wald wieder drauf
mit und in der küche steht wird man so
schossen die gerade drauf holt dann
wieder zum zutaten verwendet hat und
dafür die am ende in eine tasche gepackt
hat völlig unwichtig und da kann man gar
keine menge sicht wie verwendet hat
weiter zum beispiel von dem wasser
kastanien noch ultra viele davon obwohl
diesmal so viel in der dose waren die am
ende lieber schale und überwindet auf
jeden fall einen mixer und das turnier
auf fang erstmal an die haben nur
kleiner weil ich glaube die
schwierigsten klein bringt an beim
kochen
[Musik]
aber carroll ist auch tatsächlich einer
meiner lieblings charaktere die
kraftentwicklung mitgemacht
wir haben habe noch nie am rand wurde
sogar schon zu würden wieder ins
teamhotel aspekt gemacht jetzt mal
weiter mit dem wasser kampanien damit
eine flüssige grund mischung haben und
am ende das trockene kakaopulver und
weil dort viel hinzufügen können die
werde ich jetzt zeuge davon dass ich
keine dosen öffnen kann man kann halt
nicht alle aber nicht zu brauchen
das sind also wasser kastanien lecker
thomas schirrmacher spanien jetzt packen
wir die haare zu den back up plan jetzt
machen wir die rote webereien kann ich
öffne und rote beete ja geplant wenn ich
hätte cacau verein zufügen und fritz
mehl backpulver gar keine angebrachte
wussten immer noch liegt auf jeden fall
sehr neutral wieder auf jeden fall auch
rico noch mal ein zwei drei ist so teuer
fünf euro gekostet
juni darf noch miteinander verrühren das
wird wirklich was ich versucht nämlich
trocken genug deswegen wird mal wieder
verrückt
das ist unklar ob ihr wollt oder hempel
ich habe schon mal angemacht wir
brauchen auf jeden fall ein backblech
mit backpapier und dabei in den kleinen
kugeln drauf machen und hoffen dass
barroso wären wir machen hier immer so
aber okay wenn wir doch immer größer und
da auch wenn jetzt hoffentlich richtig
leckere brote biete wasser kampagne frei
wird vielmehr haselnuss keks mit kakao
aroma und die tiefe ist für irgendeine
zeit in den ofen zuschauen
wir werden sehen was daraus geworden ist
ich freue mich auf jeden fall etwa und
gesehen und dann gleich das ist auch der
ersten kurve kekse geworden und dann
habe ich ein bisschen was an den teig
gemacht und noch mal ich in den oben
geschmissen und ihr tun wir die mal raus
mal gucken ob die besser geworden
hilflos und das sind die karten gucken
und ich finde diese auch richtig die
rote beete cookies auf und einzige
problem ist dass die konsistenz nicht so
ganz stimmt shake shake shake und wie
immer stehen besitzt der allerwichtigste
frage wie schlink ich habe ein bisschen
eigen
der geschmack ist okay mutig sagen
rote beete und heilwasser kampanien
haselnüsse aber die konsistenz wirklich
abartig könnte sein dass ich ein
bisschen weniger findet mehr hätte
benutzen sollen bei der wie ein
bindemittel funktioniert und fremdheit
die konsistenz wenn ihr die wir auch
probiert dann benutzt offenbar weniger
familie
vielleicht werden wir dann besser aber
ansonsten würde ich sagen
schmeckt nicht gut nein nein nein wir
haben dort im supermarkt alle richtigen
zutaten zu kaufen für cookies und nicht
darauf angewiesen ich glaube aber
während einer vom bia calypso wichtig
für unser letztes problem und mit diesen
worten hoffe ich natürlich dass ich mal
wieder die folgenden gefallen hat und
wenn ihr noch weitere rezepte wie gehabt
oder wachen die auf filme und serien
nachkochen läuft ab in die kommentare
damit mit ihr habt immer so wunderbare
ideen bis 50 toll und ich freue mich
jedes mal wenn ihr euch freut wenn
jedoch nachkochen und wir sehen uns dann
mal
ich nehme meine puppen abonniert und bei
100.000 daumen nach oben ist das nicht
immer in diesem kiez bis dann